okay
did I did you just run for me sir okay
all right put your hands on your back
yeah
body camera video shows South Carolina
police take the wrong man into custody
after mistaking his license plate for
that of a suspects now he's suing the
city for civil assault he was leaving a
Burger King when he was mistaken for
someone who was involved in a high-speed
chase by the Marion Police Department
and was pulled over I mean subsequently
ordered out of his vehicle onto the
ground at gunpoint by an officer with
the police department and handcuffed
um still at gunpoint obviously giving
him a really traumatic experience
there is
right
this ain't even him
but they got almost identical tag
Challenger look just like this
you're good the incident happened on
November 20th 2022 in Marion South
Carolina David Wiggins says he was on
the way home from Burger King when he
was pulled over by police and placed in
handcuffs hands out the window
both hands you got anybody in there with
you
anybody with you
take your right hand open the door
I'm actually one of the people
on the ground on the ground
body camera video shows officers
pointing their guns at Wiggins who
continues to say he didn't run from
police
did I did you just run for me
all right put your body back
did you run for me
[Music]
give me that tag
for the 2016 Dodge Challenger last night
it's clear
after realizing they pulled over the
wrong person the responding officer
apologizes to Wiggins
right here you're good
that's scary
I'm sorry you got almost the same tax
same car you must have passed you going
through and you turn off this one yeah
we had everybody coming to do yeah
you good
all right
you have a good one okay I'm sorry about
that but Wiggins is attorney Marvin
pandarvis says that apology isn't enough
at the end of the day you know Mr
Wiggins
for three minutes for 180 seconds
he was in handcuffs
on the ground face down with a gun drawn
to him with multiple officers around him
he doesn't know ex and he didn't do
anything wrong he was flabbergasted by
the fact that he was stopped to begin
with pandarvas tells lawn crime Network
the traffic stopped traumatized Wiggins
question the officers as to why he was
being stopped and they insinuated until
backup got there they insinuated that he
was running from him and he's like I
didn't run I didn't do anything what did
I do and so being on the ground for that
long he didn't know the next breath that
he took was going to be his last and so
it really really traumatized him he's
been in therapy since then dealing with
the the effects that this has had on his
psyche um and his overall being in in
his interaction with law enforcement to
be frank he says Wiggins waited months
to file suit against the city to make
sure his team collected all the
information they needed it it happened
in November we took this long to file
the lawsuit because we wanted to do our
due diligence something that was not
afforded to Mr Wiggins when the officer
stopped him prematurely and so we wanted
to investigate to get the video talk
with people in the community kind of get
a sense of what the experiences have
been like for or motorists and people
um similarly situated now they're
alleging civil assault battery
negligence and false imprisonment during
that incident well the reason why we
filed the lawsuit because there has to
be some measure of an accountability uh
while there was an apology Mr Wiggins
and his family did have a meeting with
the police chief and they did
acknowledge that he should not have been
stopped and what happened to him was
wrong but they stopped short of calling
for an investigation into it we would
have liked them to turn the matter over
to the South Carolina law enforcement
division which is the state agency that
investigates police departments from
misconduct and they did not right they
they opted not to and we believe that a
more thorough investigation was
necessary here pandarvas says he hopes
the lawsuit Can Shed light on the
incident and prevent future situations
like this in the future you know
part of it is one of bringing
accountability to that to make sure that
we we you know there's some things that
are uncovered through the litigation
part of this then that can be brought to
the public but also to ensure that the
police department ensures that if they
they they improve their training to a
point where they can recognize and
identify people who are actual suspects
and not stop and and really cause harm
to those innocent motorists who are just
trying to get home like Mr Wiggins and
so there has to be some measure of
accountability and the lawsuit is the
first step in trying to bring that about
for Mr Wiggins his family and frankly
the community of Marion if you're going
to stop a motorist if you're going to
take the step in stopping someone
pulling them over and drawing a gun to
order them out of their vehicle you got
to be sure that you have the right
person and so there's a due diligence
that's on the part of the Marion Police
Department to make sure that that
officer is armed with correct
information that she's using the
information she's given to properly
identify suspects that are in the actual
Commission of a crime or suspected to be
committing a crime not an innocent
motorist who's just trying to get some
food and get home like Mr Wiggins was on
November 20th of 2022. in the end
pendarvis says the situation could have
ended a lot worse for Wiggins
if we don't do something now then who
knows if the next suspect is even able
to leave the scene you know thankfully
Mr Wiggins was very compliant he stopped
when he was blue lighted he got out of
the vehicle and he was ordered to he did
everything that we asked us or we asked
citizens to do
when they're stopped by the police
department to comply he did all of that
but what if he had made what was
determined to be a false move or what if
the officer thought that he was armed or
if he was a threat and there were shots
fired and all of a sudden we're talking
about a much larger situation than we
are now and all because of a mistaken
identity
at the end of the day there are certain
mistakes that cannot happen because the
consequences can be deadly and in this
situation it was inexcusable it should
not have happened and we're bringing the
lawsuit to bring about Justice and
accountability and Darvis tells me he's
been in contact with the city attorney
who now has 30 days to reply to the
lawsuit he says this is the first step
to bring Justice to Wiggins and his
family reporting for long crime Network
I'm Sierra Gillespie